today's one minute monday is take
consistent action the difference between
people who are successful and the ones
who aren't the difference between people
who achieve their goals and the ones who
don't the people the difference when
people who are living their dreams and
the ones who aren't is if you're taking
consistent action or not you need to
take consistent action do something
every single day no matter how small to
move closer to achieving your goal and I
know at the beginning that's really hard
you know when when you feel like
nobody's with you people don't believe
in what you're doing I think you're
doing something stupid will you feel
like nobody would care if you stop doing
what you're doing that's when it's
really hard and that's when it's really
important to keep taking action because
pretty soon those small steps you're
taking everyday will add up to giant
leaps forward so take consistent action
every single day do something to move
forward closer to your goals and believe
you guys like this video thumbs up below
leave a comment let me know you think
click my face subscribe to the channel
I'll see you soon